you jetted out of Beverly Hills you're
here in DC you're a busy woman why was
it important that you take time out of
your schedule to be here at history
talks um you know what history is so
important I mean this is why I came to
this country as an immigrant is really
to sort of put my stamp on the world and
also learn about so many other people
like I didn't know about Catherine
Johnson until I saw hidden figures
history is important I want to know more
I want my kids to know more so this was
an opportunity that I couldn't pass up
first the White House last night
Elton John performed hello and then
today which is incredible the lineup I
just met Julia Roberts she said oh my
God I need to find you a boyfriend I'm
invested in this and I said I can die
now like I don't even need the boyfriend
she needs a boyfriend you got anyone in
mind no but I'm going to be thinking
about it all day Julia Roberts wants to
be your Cupid your Matchmaker oh did you
exchange numbers you gotta make this
happen
he said I need a moment when she saw me
and I was like are you kidding I need a
moment oh my God so she's definitely a
real housewives of Beverly Hills fan or
she's possibly a fan of the real I know
I certainly was congratulations on a
great run what is what is life like for
you now that you're in a new chapter you
know New Hampshire I'm open to so many
things I want to produce I want to spend
time with my kids before they go off to
college even though they just started
High School
um I just wanted continue doing what I
what I love to do and that's being an
artist
it's the day-to-day of going there and
being with those ladies and talking
about important topics I do I do I
really felt like that was a niche that
we had that we could talk about our
community and even though we were women
of color we had different perspectives
and different views so I hope I get to
do it again one day soon because that's
really the platform I enjoy
and you're so good at it too I spoke
with Adrian and I said you know we live
in an age of reboots yes we could
definitely reboot the real absolutely
would you want to be a part of it
because Adrian said I would rather sit
and talk every day about myself I don't
necessarily love talking about other
people I want to do it I want to talk
about people's business
I would do it anyway of course right
yeah Adrian becoming a mom
how did you react I was so happy I was
so happy I was texting her she was
texting me back and I'm like why are you
texting me back you should be busy yeah
exactly I am over the moon her Dream
came true have you met the baby not yet
they're on the East Coast while I was I
might I go back to New York tomorrow
yeah I mean is the group chat online a
lot yes the group chat is alive sounds
like you gotta swing by Chateau Houghton
a gummy baby ever potent looks amazing
and it's so fun of course to see you on
Housewives of Beverly Hills tell me
about where you stand in all of this
Kathy Hilton conga line drama Kathy is
not on the plane with us today because
she had a
breakdown at the nightclub that we were
all at Kathy was just a little off she
kept asking everybody to do the conga
lot
and I don't think anybody wanted to do
it oh my God I love Kathy I just feel
like we all have meltdowns you know
things happen you know and I just feel
like she's a lovely lady and uh you know
I'm glad the season's over
more of housewives in your future you
want to come back and do more you gotta
ask Bravo
and just being here at history talks
when you think about your history what
do you hope people remember most
wow I think for me uh
I came from a country that no one
expected anything from me and I feel
like I've lived the American dream you
know I've been able to leave my stamp
here and there and I think that's what
being an immigrant is about we bring
something also to the country it's not
just that we want to take we also bring
and so it's important for us to be
inclusive of all people yeah and I'm
happy to be here
[Music]